sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager on solana bitmex the
og crypto derivatives platform and
the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys anna welcome back to another episode of
the leia heil pen show so this show as you should
know by now is sponsored by the cryptocurrency
exchange bitmex so as of may the 17th so it's been
now they're launching a brand new spot exchange
to easily and instantly buy and sell crypto so to
celebrate the launch of this sport exchange they
are giving away one million dollars in crypto to
spot traders over the next few months and this is
one of the biggest giveaways i've personally seen
in crypto so if you do want to enter i'm going to
leave the link for you and more information about
that in the description below that's on youtube um
it's gonna be really exciting there's a huge range
of different assets that you can um have access
to so i just want to say a massive shout out and
a big thank you to bitmex because without them
we wouldn't be able to bring you such interesting
conversations conversations which we're sort
of not really allowed to have these days um so
i'm happy that bimx are basically helping us get
the word out there um about all the rubbish that
is going on in the world right now so if you are
watching on youtube please don't forget to hit
the subscribe button because we're always gonna
bring you top quality guests and we're going to
be talking about some of the craziest things in
the world right now um which really is you know
the clamping down on freedom of speech so joining
me today is kenny florian a former ufc competitor
and carla commentator for pfl and a battle bot
let's bring it kenny in kenny welcome to the
show how are you i'm well thanks thanks for having
me yeah it's my pleasure i'm super excited to chat
with you um you are i think the third fighter
i've had on the show um what's going on why are
all you fighters interested in crypto um i think
you're more specifically interested in bitcoin but
we'll get to that um but why are you into crypto
what's the connection here yeah you know it's a
good question i guess i'll speak for myself here
um yeah i got in the space i guess in like 2017
um got into you know crypto in general uh and
then eventually you know just moved into bitcoin
i think about a year year and a half later um
so i i think for me i like the idea uh first of
all of you know doing things that are a little bit
differently uh they're a little bit different from
what other people are doing um and uh i i think
that um i guess i'm a little bit more open-minded
to things and um i also think i i have i put a
tremendous value on my time um as well and um
i i i was really intrigued with the idea um of of
bitcoin uh and and what it does and what it could
do and um you know especially for the future i
think um i've always kind of been an optimist and
okay um have always looked for ways to um you
know i guess be most efficient with my time and
my energy and what i put into things and um yeah
and i've always been curious about investing and
having um my money grow and um i guess back
in 2015 2016 when i first heard about bitcoin
that was intriguing to me um and then um you know
uh i kind of went solely into that i guess about
2018. so um yeah and and then i i think like
so many other people it kind of drags you into
um this rabbit hole of of more
information um and kind of unites many
different modalities like philosophy and economics
and history and um so many of those things and
and you realize over time that i think
the root of many of our of our issues
has always been the manipulation of money and
fiat currencies and um i i think i i i don't
know if everything can be solved by that but i
do think that uh much of the world's plight is is
i guess revolving around that issue um you know
so yeah but help me here because i know and i can
just tell from your answer that it's so much more
about money right like you mentioned philosophy um
and i want to go deeper into this and i
want to understand the connection between
um you know being sovereign over
your assets um and fighting right and
my my like two cents or two satoshis if
you like is you know when you get in the
ring you have to take personal responsibility
right like you gotta train otherwise you're
getting absolutely destroyed i don't know if
there's a connection there what do you think
no question about it i think that's spot on um you
realize that you are responsible for you um in a
lot of ways and the truth will reveal itself in
combat um and there is no hiding for the most part
uh in the cage or in the ring um and you know the
work that you put in um you know especially over
time is the work that you get is what you're gonna
get out of it and um i think that um there's a lot
to that and having that person responsibility um
i think is huge for a lot of fighters and um you
know i think believing in yourself and having that
faith in yourself and believing in um hard work
and try not to let anybody take that away from
you i think is important and i think over time
um you know you start to realize the value of
freedom and your ability to do things that you
do and the things that you gain and the things
that you literally fight for that you become um
very protective of that and very protective of
your time uh and what you spend um your energy
on yeah so you in order to survive in this career
you had to take personal responsibility you had to
um you know work extremely hard and i guess like
you said it's you don't want that taken away from
you um and so politically i'm always sort of
finding that fighters tend to fall on one side
of the spectrum so why so so what happened when
you started to be orange pilled um did you share
this conversation with other fighters and do
you think they tend to have a similar opinion
yeah i i don't think all fighters share the same
opinion but i do think the majority of fighters do
um i definitely agree with you that i agree with
you on that um i have had uh many conversations
with with various fighters um on on bitcoin uh
and you know ex i guess doing my best to explain
how i see things um and what is going on and um i
i think they start to see the same things and um
yeah they eventually kind of fall down that rabbit
hole as well um so yeah i think that um you know
understanding that valuing your time and um you
know having that personal personal responsibility
uh has a lot to do with a lot of people in
the mixed martial arts space getting into you
know bitcoin and i guess other cryptos as well
i mean speaking about the cryptos when i was
preparing the show i was like damn this guy's
a bitcoin maxi i didn't realize how hard on
bitcoin you are so how did you come to the
realization that bitcoin was the main currency for
you and am i correct you're a bitcoin maxi right
yeah i would say so um i think that uh you know
i am the kind of person that uh like a lot of
people i guess i i learn best by making a lot of
stupid mistakes i guess and and so i think that
i i i am open-minded and at times that can be um a
strength it can also be a weakness at times um and
i've experimented with other cryptocurrencies um
but and and sometimes you hear the thing of like
okay well this is decentralized and this is a
little bit more centralized but not as much but
it's got technology that's a little bit more
modern a little bit more advanced and it could
do this and that but what i find is that um you
know from investing in some other cryptocurrencies
what i find is that um they also come to
the same um i guess single points of failure
and all succumb to uh manipulation or
um i guess overall [__] if you will
um you know of just different things happening
whether it's um you know the majority of investors
you know getting in before everyone else does
and you know pre you know pre-mining or um you
know just kind of taking their money out and then
leaving everyone else you know to hold their bags
and everyone getting screwed so i've been through
a few of those um and not that i invested a ton of
money in it um but when i did trade some bitcoin
for those things i was like man if i just held
bitcoin i would have been fine and then i guess
as i do more research into it or as i did more
research into it um i started realizing of you
know there's just so many um less vulnerabilities
with bitcoin than than some of the other um coins
so as i you know realized that over time i i just
transitioned and sold everything else
that i had and put it all into bitcoin
like i said around 2018 uh and have just
i've just noticed that i'm just a lot more
um calm and not trying to you know uh let you know
try try to you know score a a um you know this big
gain with a certain cryptocurrency or whatever i'm
not so stressed i'm just kind of being like this
is the thing there's a reason why um you know that
they have the highest market cap there's a reason
why um it has less vulnerabilities so it's just
has kind of given me more confidence over time
um having seen the ups and downs everywhere
and having seen how bitcoin has has improved
and increased um and become more popular overall
especially amongst large uh financial institutions
uh it's given me more and more confidence that
that's the way to go yeah i mean i think uh one
cycle will do that to you right like 2018 to
get to become a bitcoin maxi sounds about right
i think a lot of bitcoin maxies are being created
right now um but you you mentioned philosophy so i
want to get into that i really want to understand
you know because some people just look at bitcoin
as um you know great technology some people look
at it as hedge against inflation others look at it
as just you know gains or whatever um but for you
it's philosophical what does that mean oh geez i
mean um i think there's a lot to it but i guess
the idea that um no one gets the opportunity to
uh mess with um the currency no one gets to
really mess with the value it's a true free
market and it's the free market really playing
itself out um and i i think that um you know
if you are in charge of the money if you are in
charge of the currency um it a lot of times the
i guess the things like greed is going to take
over or things like opportunity is going to take
over and um i've found that when you have
a certain group of people that is managing
things like that um it's just it becomes way too
difficult for them to keep their hands out of the
cookie jar um and you know it's it's happened
throughout time and you look at the history of
fiat currencies i mean there's hundreds and
hundreds of fiat currencies that have failed
um and there's like a legit you know certain
time of that like i think the average time is
like 95 years or something like that but most
of them are in and out within like 25 years
my parents actually come from south america
they were both born in peru um and i i know
in my lifetime they've gone through i think two
or three different currencies and i remember them
talking about um that and how you know the dollar
was so much stronger over there as a kid and
you know um so that was always kind of
fascinating to me but um i think there is this um
beautiful open network called the bitcoin
network that allows for everyone and anyone
all over the world to be a part of it um and for
me um one thing that i've always tried to do which
is an important part of my ethos i guess is just
evolving uh i am you know constantly trying to
become a better martial artist a better person a
better dad and all those things and um you know
um i i feel like um it is a natural part
of of evolution is to find a money that
can't be messed with and i feel like um
bitcoin is our kind of best hope of that
um and you know everything from game theory to um
you know peace to um you know uniting everybody
uh under one kind of methodology that is actually
fair um i i think was was very intriguing to me
yeah and i think you know speaking of uniting
what i tend to find and what i personally love
is how bitcoiners tend to see the world
in a certain way which is a more logical
realistic and truthful reality um so something
which i see you're quite vocal on um is
just the world right now um in terms of um the
incorrect information that's pushed down our
throats um you know we were told that inflation
is transitory um we've seen them try and say
that inflation is good because of higher wages
i think i saw something about it's inflation is
good because it's better for the environment i
don't know what rubbish i read but i'm curious
given that our leaders are supposed to be experts
in the fields that they operate why do you think
we are receiving so much false information
right now um again i think a lot of it is
motivated by two things money and power
and um i think it is to their benefit um to
give people certain information um or uh
suppress certain information i mean again
i i don't think it's any coincidence that in um in
the united states uh specifically i would imagine
worldwide that uh we are not taught truly um how
how the fiat system actually works um yeah and
that that information which is suppressed um you
know keeps a lot of people down uh in the dark and
um i think everything in general is an information
game those that are privy to the information those
that have the right information will succeed
those that do not um it not saying that they
will fail but it's gonna be more difficult for
them to succeed um and uh it's it's become this
uh game of information uh suppressing information
disinformation and saying what is politically
i guess favorable to them um and whether it's a
politician or any kind of leader in whatever space
or people that are benefiting from
the system of course they're going to
you know fight something that threatens their
way of life it's this is human nature in general
uh and when you begin to see these lies pile up
and you get and you get a chance to see the other
side of it or you get to see you know behind
the curtain which you haven't had access to
and then all of a sudden you see it and you see
more evidence of it um then uh you realize that
this is a game that has been played for a
very long time whether you're talking about
um you know the religious institutions that have
had power the religious institutions that have
had power um you know monarchies whatever it
is um you know from all over the world um it's
there is this struggle um to gain power and
keep power and um yeah that that's kind of been
something that has been quite
enlightening to me i guess
was that something that you discovered through
bitcoin or you or you sort of felt before bitcoin
um i definitely felt it before bitcoin uh just
i don't know you look at any space in a field of
so-called experts um let's take the mixed martial
arts space for example and i'm listening to
so-called experts talk about it or a journalist
talk about mixed martial arts and they're saying
a certain thing which i know is absolutely false
or inaccurate um you know i i just like this
that's not how it is that's not how the game is
and if these people are are saying these things
either they're ignorant they're spreading
information uh purposely um to throw people off
or they're just not very good at their jobs and
i think it's a combination of all three uh and
yeah so i mean if it's happening in
that space and then of course it's
happening all over the world like i don't
believe there are many true experts in
different fields i i just don't i don't buy it i
i think that there's a lot of incompetent people
everywhere and a lot of people do what is
necessary to do their job and just that and
then there's a lot of people who don't even do
that i mean how many people are just sitting there
miserable at their jobs and um are putting in
minimal effort and you know getting through their
nine to five uh so you start looking at other
aspects of it and other areas of expertise and
you know you start to realize well this is
happening everywhere and um i don't know and
i mean again how many times have we seen just
blatantly false uh information about bitcoin
uh and these are like the biggest publications in
the world and you start realizing we're being lied
to or again people just aren't very good at their
jobs so the thing is i think i would say that
more people are waking up to this realization
that we're being lied to and particularly the
whole men can get pregnant thing like that that's
just this weird thing that's like popped up in the
last few weeks um but my question is so it's 2022
and we can have these conversations and i don't
think we'd be called conspiracy theorists but if
we had it maybe like two years ago people would
call us conspiracy theorists so i'm interested
do you think that like elites world leaders the
davos people because davos is going on right
now um do you think they overplayed their
hand to some extent over the last two three
years and now you know people are waking up
i think yeah to a certain extent and
i still think people are are still
asleep um and not saying i think a lot of
people are awakening are waking up to it
uh but when you see such compliance globally
uh with certain things that are in play and
i i think they became more emboldened by it and
kind of are saying what a lot of the conspiracy
theorists were kind of thinking um and
also framing it in different ways and
being very subtle in in how they uh explain what
they're doing um a lot of this is about control
um you know uh for those that have ever you
know lived in a community which has this hoa
which which kind of are these board members in the
community that manage the neighborhood um there's
there's a lot of tricky things that going on that
go on there and again not necessarily malicious
but um humans in general aren't great at managing
things and when you talk about things like the
economy or you know um the government in general
in these massive countries with complicated
infrastructure and all these things up like
you're not going to get it right and also like
as far as you know if we had 10 people and we all
asked them what would be the best way to manage
you know let's say a town a city a state a
country um it's going to be a debate over control
how do we control or allow for the citizenry
to operate and there's varying approaches and
theories on that and for many people they
like nodding their head and saying yes and
i trust whatever the government they have our
best interests and i'm gonna do whatever they
say and um i think there's a lot of danger in
that um and uh you know i think we we forget
especially in this country that um the freedoms
that uh we fought for and the freedoms that built
this country and the idea of the united states is
what makes us um powerful and i think we're giving
away a lot of those liberties um willingly um not
knowing uh and not thinking about the long term
you mentioned um before the church you know
monarchies these traditional institutions from
you know way back when when you know
they would control pretty much everything
um i've spoken to a few people um and they sort
of talk about us reaching peak centralization
in 2025 and we do in fact eventually move
on to this bitcoin standard um meaning this
decentralized standard essentially um so we've
seen the power dynamics change we've seen the
power hierarchies change do you think the way
the world is now and the you know the supposed
democracy that we have all these these two to the
two system parties um do you think that's gonna
change and we actually will move to a
decentralized standard oh geez i i don't know
i i fear what happens if we go too far the other
way i mean if too much centralization happens
can we go back the other way that that i think
is the question um especially in regards to um
whether it's military control or um you know
that whoever is in control with governmental
or otherwise uh in their ability to uh invade our
privacies and and how we operate and where we're
going and how we do things um i i i fear for that
and like you said a lot of that is being masked by
um you know doing things what's good for the
environment and what's hilarious and and i'm
not the first to point this out of course but
it's like all these people that are flying into
you know the world economic forum uh conferences
on their private jets and you know getting picked
up and and their huge rolls royces or whatever and
you know having the biggest homes in the world and
having you know 40 cars or whatever are the people
that are telling us how we should be um living our
lives to lessen the impact on the environment i
think what's really going on uh is that i think
they view it as a population issue now why is
it a population issue is because um the more
that uh and this is you know my opinion i guess
that if there is a larger middle class amongst
this large population of let's say 8 billion
people um that means that those people are
going to be consuming more resources and if
they're consuming more resources that means
that there's less resources for those people
at the top so if we can lessen population um or
keep people uh at an economic disadvantage that
means that they they don't eat up the resources
that i you know get to value at the top um i could
keep everything for myself um and battle it out
with you know uh my other wealthy friends so i
i think that's kind of what's going on and we're
seeing that kind of play out already with with
supply chains and energy issues and all that stuff
and i think that's really what it's about it's
um i want these resources for me uh and uh
and i think that's kind of where this
economic disempowerment is coming from
um whether it's you know false narratives
or disinformation uh and things like that
the reality is that every energy source or any
type of energy production has its advantages
and disadvantages no matter uh whether it's green
energy or you know uh oil or whatever it is um it
is what it is and there's no easy solution uh with
with with any of them um so i i i don't buy that
narrative i think it's uh i i don't know anyways
that's that those are my thoughts on that no i
i agree with you you're so awake i love it um i i
just with everything that's going on in the world
right now i find it so hard to have conversations
with people that just don't see what i see um like
i was at a gathering just a few weeks ago and
i i was having a conversation with this guy and
obviously it got political because politics just
runs through my veins um and i'd said to him i was
like yeah i mean you have a president that like
can't even string a full sentence together and he
was like that's a conspiracy i'm like what do you
mean i was like what do you mean i don't know i'm
not i was like he can't i've seen the videos and
he's like that's a conspiracy and i'm like what
do you mean like how is like okay they complain
about the environment right and then you've got
them all flying in on private jets surely if
they've really cared about the environment they
would have hopped on economy together you know
on like american airlines i don't know if you're
coming in from europe get on ryanair easyjet but
they don't do it yeah so why are people so asleep
yeah i don't know again it's um again any the
problem is is that like you can justify a lot
of different narratives and you can argue in a
lot of different ways and the key is you know
and this is a very common saying don't uh don't
listen to what they say watch what they do and and
i think that's the key and people who are on the
inside and and see these things really playing out
uh know what the deal is and um people just aren't
being very honest about it well here's something
more positive um elon musk is speaking out about
it um jeff bezos is trying to be elon musk i think
he's now sort of like talking about inflation
he's sort of you know calling out all this bs
um which is fascinating because before you
know your conspiracy theorist and you're you're
you're de-platformed and everything um so do you
think more major influential businessmen ceos
are going to start speaking out about this even
celebrities remember kanye west was probably a
bit too early to speak out about it um so do you
think more will and then maybe that might wake
up more of the population i think so and i hope
so i i think that um at the end of the day what
people need to realize no matter what kind of
position or what kind of uh power you have um
is that uh eventually they will come for you yeah
no matter what you say or or what you do um and if
you are just sitting there and being controlled by
a certain narrative or afraid to speak your mind
then this is what people in positions of power
want um and people need to realize we don't live
in china we live we live in the united states and
freedom of speech and our ability to say what's on
our mind is one of the most important things that
we have as a country if that fails everything else
falls apart after that and you know i i could even
you know speak for myself you know i i have a job
i'm in media um you know not that i have this you
know burning desires to say all these different
things to all these different people but you know
you do feel a little bit limited at times right um
but i think when you're a jeff bezos or or elon
musk and you're like wait a sec i am one of the
richest and most powerful people in the world
maybe i should be saying what's on my mind maybe
the media is going to say bad things about me
regardless and uh it's on me to just you know
speak my mind and and fight back to what's going
on here um and if you don't you're a major part
of the problem especially if you have the power to
be able to change things um and influence things
um not everyone is is uh influencing things
in a positive direction or um you know for
the majority of people um but i i think that
people are catching on and starting to see
that um you know this uh this curtain is starting
to come down and and things are being revealed
yeah i think so and that's one of the things that
i love about crypto and i also think um it's part
of the reason why they're so anti-bitcoin is
just because of the because we've created this
community and safe haven safe space i hate that
term um but to talk about these things um and i
actually did a podcast yesterday and somebody um
they were london people um and they were really
surprised at how blunt and to the point i was
and they you know they just weren't used to it
in the uk they were just like oh my god like if
we said that we'd lose our jobs and so i find
so much peace and like kind of reassurance in
this community because you can say these things
yeah i think one of the things that is being lost
um majorly especially when it comes to education
and just the overall narrative is independent
thinking is completely being lost and and i
guess to go back to your first question i think
that's another thing in regards to fighters is
that you must think independently if you just
follow what is taught to you then you are more
liable to repeat mistakes and get caught in
the cage with those things you have to be able
to think outside the box and be creative and go
what is going to truly give me the best results
not for joe or rick or sarah or whatever
what is going to give me the best results
for my performance in this fight against
this person so you have to be willing to um
i guess be be combative in a variety of ways and
how you see things and how you train and how you
approach things um because you ultimately are the
one that's going to either succeed or fail um so
yes you have a team around you and you hope
that you have the best people around you but
the individual fighter uh you know ends up
taking the responsibility um you know really
at the end of the day and you have to be able
to think independently uh you know to try to
find the best result possible and i think that is
something that is is being lost today for sure in
the education system and uh and otherwise so um i
hope that this spurs a new um you know i guess um
age of independent thinking uh especially
in a world where there's so much information
you have to be able to comb through it
and find out what what really is the truth
and um it's not always so clear you're gonna have
to do the work and investigate for yourself truly
um not just follow a conspiracy theory or follow
what the media is is is saying sometimes it's
somewhere in the middle or maybe somewhere where
it's not even out there you have to just go out
and find and really think for yourself on you
know logically of what what is it going on what
is making sense and to be able to connect the dots
in in an intelligent way i think you make a really
important point because i actually um think that
life is the ring like i think life is the jungle
and i think people don't realize how i don't know
if this is a british term but doggy dog we say
i don't know if that's you know is that okay i
don't know yeah yeah how how doggy dog it is and
just how rough it is um and that's why you have so
many soft pe soft and entitled individuals because
they think that they're entitled to an easy life
they think they're entitled to all these things
um and you know you're in the ring and you
know you're are you entitled to to that belt
no are you entitled to the money no you have
to work for it and i think that is why physical
challenge is so important um in creating a better
society no question about it i think it um it
it identifies a more accurate picture
of where you fit into the world
but also you realize that everything is struggle
i mean if you want to succeed in anything
you have to know what failure is like and you have
to know what it's like to come back from failure
and you have to be able to pick yourself up uh
and also as you succeed as you start climbing
that ladder remember what it was like to be in
that position and to constantly understand that
we live in an evolving world that is surrounded
by chaos and it's up to us to be able to interpret
that chaos uh evolve and adapt you know we we've
lived for we've lived very well for a long time
especially here in the united states where anytime
i go to the supermarket i can get eggs i can get
milk i can get chicken i can get whatever the
heck i want i can go to my fancy supermarkets
well what's happening now is that those things
aren't available anymore you know some of those
things anyway or the majority of those things
are becoming more and more expensive now
i'm in a position where it's not so much of a big
deal for for for someone like me thankfully but
for a lot of people that are on a very strict
budget with large families or whatever it is
what happens when milk isn't readily available
what happens when um eggs aren't readily available
water you know simple things that we take for
granted um you know energy sources all these
things the people are going to revolt and it's
not going to be pretty uh those that are weak
will be left behind um those that are stronger
you know physically economically whatever it is
um will probably succeed so it is i i agree with
you i i think that um you know it we all the way
from like the most basic form of uh the most basic
life forms all the way to the most complicated
ones there's a battle going on all the time um
and a lot of it is a battle for resources and
you know the most intelligent and
well positioned creatures will succeed
how do you position yourself that's the
question well how do you position yourself
i think that's what it comes down to right it's
like well when when things get crazy and when the
money is being manipulated um what will remain i
i do think that um you know game theory and um a
lot of other things uh efficiency speed uh ease of
of maneuvering i think bitcoin is that answer that
people will have to transition to now do you want
to have to make that choice or do you want to um
be positioned before you have to make that
choice and i think that's what it comes down to
but i do think things like the lightning
network is uh one of those uh things that has
really taken things to to a whole new level uh
to ultimately lead bitcoin down that uh media
exchange medium of exchange route um you know
i i think bitcoin is one of those things that
if you have money saved uh and you wanted to store
it indefinitely forever um that was the answer
but as far as medium of exchange i think like
the lightning network has taken things to a
whole new level um which is very exciting
it's still very early um but um i i that's
what i think uh bitcoin is is about is now it's
extremely volatile and people always point to that
but um you know what happens when you have no
other place to go what happens when you can't
park your money anywhere else what happens when
financial institutions governments realize that
uh they're in a losing game uh and they have
nowhere to go um it's it's going to be interesting
so we have this civil war coming um we've got the
middle class dying out um it's all pretty terrible
um so how where do you see bitcoin then in like
10 years from now you know you mentioned medium
of exchange um do you actually think we're gonna
get onto a bitcoin standard like do you think
this is what i think just honest just to make my
question a bit clearer i feel like all of us who
are orange peeled or red pilled or whatever it
is are gonna just form this society somewhere
whether you know whether texas breaks off
i don't know i don't think that's to happen
whether it's latin america i don't know
i think geographically we're all going
to be we're going to move together and live in
this kind of like parallel alternative society
what do you think it's quite possible
i mean i think that's kind of
happening with with the current wealthy
right and i think that every generation
kind of experiences that whether it's a tech boom
or the oil barons of the past or you know the big
industrial complexes that have been formed uh
throughout you know the ages i think that um
there's another one that's going to come and
um is that going to be bitcoin i think so um
but um i don't know you know obviously it
remains to be seen um but when you look at
what's happening and you look at you know
the fact that there aren't many answers to
many of the issues that are going on i
think bitcoin satisfies a lot of those
needs and you know there's a lot of governments
that are experiencing a lot of issues everywhere
and the united states isn't uh as powerful
as it used to be and if you look at you know
the ideals the american ideals and the
philosophies uh and the men that helped you
know to [__] to find this country and develop
you know the constitution all those things i mean
what's more american than bitcoin and um it
comes down to uh do you want to lead or do you
want to have to follow and when you're talking
about a finite resource or finite set of assets
it's it's going to be yet another battle for
those for those resources for those assets which
i think bitcoin will be um and you look at where
we're heading everything is turning more digital
uh and i i think it simplifies things in a lot of
different ways uh so i'm i'm real i'm real curious
to see what that timeline is is it five years is
it 10 years is it 20 is it 30 i don't know but
i think that when it happens it's going to be uh
very very quickly as they say gradually gradually
then suddenly so um i i think that's that's the
way it is and it's like you know adoption uh
begets adoption and it spreads out you know kind
of far and wide but then all of a sudden it's just
going to be um this tunnel and this massive
um accumulation of of resources very quickly
uh in order to save themselves now i totally
agree with you and i think it's going to be so
interesting to see how it all plays out um
but i want to talk a little bit about fighting
um because that's sort of what you're well that
is what you're known for from from uh from before
all of this um so let's get into it you've been
in multiple main event title fights um with many
other big names like jose aldo and bj penn so i
always ask um fighters what goes through your mind
being the last walk out for a title fight um you
know you're the last one there how do you handle
that kind of pressure and you got the music going
and it's just a lot isn't it it is i think that um
the biggest thing and i don't think i really was
aware of it in the moment but it's such a simple
answer and it feels like i'm you know choosing uh
you know the easiest thing to say but it really is
very true it's uh really connecting to your breath
if you're not very connected to yourself um and if
you're not breathing properly i think that you're
not going to be very present and when you're not
very present you're not focused on the task
at hand and you start looking at what's on the
periphery like things like the fans the fact that
you are the last fight the fact that it's for the
world championship belt the fact that there's so
much money on the line there's so much pressure on
the line your friends family people are watching
all over the world and you know i'm nervous
being afraid to fail all those things which
really don't serve you in the moment um
and and the reality is is that you know
for for me i i put in so many hours of um
you know love and passion and sweat blood and
tears literally into my craft that it's just
another day of me trying to perform those
skills that i've accumulated over the years
but it's hard to stay focused on that task
especially you know doing the interviews all
week and the press conferences and everyone asking
the same questions and you start to think like the
other people on the outside and that is something
that i think i really didn't understand so well
as a fighter as a professional athlete um and you
know it's like you know okay just stay present
all right that's fine how do i do that um and
i think it's staying as calm as possible how do
you stay calm breathing connecting to yourself
um you know taking yourself out of the picture
if you need to isolate yourself so i would i
would try to do those things but i don't i'm
not sure i understood the importance of
um breath and meditation and how to stay
as present as possible and um those are things
that i'm still learning and trying to understand
uh to this very day so i think i'm probably
way more positioned to compete better at uh i'm
gonna be 47 in a couple days uh at this age but my
body is broken down you know when i was young and
you know uh you know full of energy and ready to
go i i didn't have that uh ability to always get
centered i'd have amazing performances and i'd be
like how did i was like in the flow how did i do
that how did that happen it's because i wasn't
trying i was just you know staying present and
not understanding that process um you know and
still trying to understand that process um is
is a fascinating thing yeah i mean ultimately you
know it's a performance um and like when before i
perform if i'm like going on the news or whatever
like all those like negative like thoughts come to
my head and i have to like breathe it out so like
how do you how do you i know you talk about breath
but like can we go into this a little bit more
how do you remove the negative thoughts you know
and because it's a lot yeah i know for sure the
the mind is really um it's such an amazing thing
right um but i don't think it has it plays a great
part in performance to be honest i think that um
how we're able to clean and wipe that mind clean
uh and start from a new i think is the key that's
when we're truly alive and aware and i think
i have the the wonderful honor and opportunity
of seeing that play out uh with my kids like
forgetting that uh a tree or great weather
or grass or something as as simple as that that
we take for granted of how amazing that is and um
our mind will either uh make something a bigger
deal or not or um you know you'll kind of look
past certain things and you won't appreciate
certain things in the moment i think one of the
easier ways to kind of talk about something
like that as far as performance is i guess
walking i guess a tight wire or a rope a tight
rope um if that thing is one foot off the ground
we could probably cross that tightrope like it's
not a big deal why because our mind is visualizing
it's like okay that's only a foot off the ground
if we fall it's not a big deal and you'll go
and do that 30 times and you'll be totally fine
whereas we'll take that exact same tightrope and
we'll put it between two buildings you know at the
top of new york city and all of a sudden it's a
very different thing now it is because if we make
that mistake right we're screwed but did it really
change it really didn't but our mind sees it as so
much different and now we're sweating and you know
we're we're seeing it as this completely different
thing so i think our ability to calm down and um
you know i guess take things from the periphery
and be able to shut it out or bring things in
to focus on it's how we're able to focus on the
important things or what we should be focusing on
and also be able to kind of delete and uh
take away the things that don't serve us and
i guess being able to siphon through those
things and figure out what those things are
uh it can be uh i guess not not to use a pun but
a balancing act right no i like the punish kid
perception really is reality um you're totally
right it's why um they always say the cliche
like imagine the audience in their underwear or
something like that you know so the pressure's
off it you know it's not so important anymore you
know you're not you're not gonna fall between the
two buildings um the pressure's off um but it's
actually interesting because um i i i sort of
follow ufc while i did more when i was younger and
because my brother was really really into it um
but there's a lot of fighters and competitors um
of the usc that claim the promotion has a monopoly
on mma um we've also seen um gsp become very
influential in creating a union for fighters so
i want to know if you think the fc has this
anti-trust issue and are you pro the union the
unionization of sport yeah i think that uh whether
the ufc has a monopoly or not um i think you know
certainly there's a lot of other organizations
that you can point to like the pfl bellator uh
you know one fc uh that have um you know a great
organization with that gives fighters options
i think where the problem lies is are the
claims that fighters are independent contractors
so when let's say an organization like the
ufc hires a so-called independent contractor
they sign them to let's say three fights
six fights eight fights 12 fights they're
an independent contractor but they can't fight
for anyone else yeah so that's where i think the
issues lie um and i know you know that the ufc
has had some issues i guess with some of their
contracts and whether those were legally valid or
fair um and that's kind of where their issues um
have been in the past so i i don't know as far
as uh unionization or uh power to the fighters
absolutely i think that uh fighters should
have way more power there should be more
bargaining power for them they should have the
ability to um especially if they're in those
main events uh to get more money and get more
power um as far as negotiation how much they can
make you know obviously francis delgado who is
a bitcoiner as well is kind of involved in that
uh sort of drama right now uh so i wish
him the best i hope he's able to do it but
it becomes difficult for fighters
to unionize i guess especially if um
there are certain fighters that are going
to be in more main events than say someone
who's on the lower tier so i guess what
what needs to happen is the fighters do
need to come together and they need to
figure out uh what determines the pay
for certain fighters and i think that's it's going
to take time um and that needs to be hashed out um
but um some some kind of uh determination of what
fighters should be paid based on experience uh
what what you know where they lie on the main
card is it a main event is it a non-main event
are they a prelim uh is this for a top 10 ranking
is it for a top 20 ranking a top 50 ranking is it
unranked fighters is this your first fight is it
debut so there's a lot of different tiers which
i think the fighters uh kind of fall into
and finding out what that pay is for that
uh level um i think is the tricky thing um i i
hope they're they're able to figure out over time
but certainly you know an organization like the
ufc is very powerful and and you know they have
the means uh you know legally and economically uh
to be very dominant over the fighters who have yet
to really come together so i i hope some kind of
uh resolution uh is able to uh transpire i guess
in the next well in the near future anyway the
reason i ask is because obviously you're a bitcoin
maxim we all know um you know what bitcoin stands
for its philosophy in terms of um free enterprise
free enterprise and capitalism um so do you feel
i know you you know you want to have more power
to the fighters but do you feel this sort of
goes against the free market in capitalism
yeah i mean that's the thing it's it's a
tricky one you know because i also think that
um the fighters do determine that um i think
that uh here's where it gets tricky is that
um the fighters need to uh fight for their value
right you have the guys like conor mcgregor who
has you know uh because of his performances and
because of his name and notoriety over time has
uh demanded um you know tens of millions
of dollars uh to go out there and perform
um and he's got the numbers to back it up um
and you know those pay-per-view numbers uh
you know at the end kind of determine his value
um and the ufc determines his value based on the
numbers that he brings in for for the company um
but i think that when you let's say compare it to
other um you know i guess leagues like the nfl
or nba or whatever uh and you look at what the
ufc fighters are being paid and how much how
much the organization is being how much that
how much is being brought in by the organization
um you know it's not it's not on the same
uh level as say the nfl so i don't know i mean i
don't have enough of uh the the economic knowledge
of the different the various leagues uh you know
specifically of what is being brought in and what
is being paid out to the fighters but i do think
there's a large discrepancy um and i think it's
up to the fighters to either come together or
not or um you know don't complain and go out
there and do their best to um win the fights that
they need to win and and go from there um but uh
it is tricky and like you said i i think
that um you know with with the free market um
i i think the options um can be somewhat
limited you know the ufc is certainly
um a leader in mixed martial arts and you have
the best opportunity to make money in the ufc
um but and and it's still new so i think
there's a lot to be worked out and um
yeah it's just a different environment
also than when i was fighting certainly
in what way um well you know i i guess people
might call me one of the early pioneers but there
was ufc fighters way before me you know starting
in 1993 um i was in the ufc in like 2005. so
uh certainly the economics have changed
significantly i think there was like the ufc was
purchased in i guess the late 90s or early
2000s for like a couple million dollars two
million dollars they're now they were purchased
um what five years ago uh by wwme for 4.2 or 4.4
billion dollars so um just that alone kind of
shows you how far we've gone um as far as you
know the business and what they're able to bring
in um so kenny what are you working on now um you
know what what are you doing um i know you have
a podcast and what's going on with you personally
yeah um thanks yeah so i have podcast uh john
anik who's uh the the play by play commentator for
the ufc uh we have a podcast together called
the aniket flooring podcast where we recap
um you know mixed martial arts news and fights
that are happening uh throughout the week
um and i am doing um color commentary for the pfl
uh they do shows on espn um and right now we're we
have our uh regular season uh coming up we have
one more uh we have three more events coming up
for the regular season before we uh get into the
postseason uh and then i'm doing commentary for a
show called battlebots on discovery channel uh
which has been a lot of fun and uh and then i
got uh i have a um jiu jitsu instructional uh at
kennyflooringmartialarts.com for those that are
interested in in martial arts and and jiu jitsu
and uh taking their game uh uh up a notch and uh
that's pretty much it just staying
busy and uh yeah trying trying to
try to do what i love good and um where can people
follow you um i know you mentioned the jiu jitsu
but where else can people follow you get in touch
with you keep up with everything that you're doing
yeah if they want to um you know follow me i'm
at kenny florian uh at k-e-n-n-y f-l-o-r-i-a-n
uh on social media that's uh on twitter and
instagram and uh yeah hit me up kenny i wanna
thank you so much it's been such a pleasure
having you on um you know these conversations
are so hard to have sometimes um and it's just so
refreshing and just such a pleasure to speak with
like-minded people so thank you so much for
coming on uh pleasure was mine thank you so
much thanks kenny and guys thank you so much for
watching don't forget to tune in next week and hit
the subscribe button so you never miss a video
we'll see you next week bye bye say ohio pancho
you